s'il vous plaît monsieur le président à
droite tournée voit un tout petit peu
vers la gauche qu'elle préside pas vous
je pense que vous avez dit à françois
mais depuis que vous êtes parler n'est
plus le même homme même dire qu'ils en
pleine de rechute fans
de quoi vous avez parlé tous les deux
tout court n'a parlé de macron ça vous
fait plus rien la trahison et
l'humiliation toussaint un doute ou
pense à
[Musique]
es6 tahri
ne dit pas vous avez reparlé de macron
mais pas du tout
commence à créer un parti
je crois le la france pour toujours
présent pour rejoindre bonjour à tous
on fait la campagne et je suis et on est
élu et la démocratie est sauvée voilà en
gros
depuis que je suis ici je suis assailli
par des mots et des notes qui me vient
de tous les côtés c'est comme un
bombardement
permanence purquoi oui je comprends pas
je crois qu'il est guéri c'était
président de la république ce n'est pas
une maladie c'est un honneur suprême une
bénédiction des dieux main ça se discute
un nom ça se discute pas
et vraiment bons spots et 1,6 label qui
fait ça les femmes aux fourneaux ça
marche peut-être encore dans votre 16e
arrondissement mais dans la vraie vie on
n'en est plus là
dans mon 16e arrondissement comme vous
dites et nous sommes des femmes c'est
traiteur
en plus c'était génial vote rue du
président normal ça veut absolument rien
dire et en même temps ces huit ans c'est
pas rester évident très longtemps
nous avons déjà consulté nos amis dérape
et que le d'europe eq lol j arrive
jamais avec leur nom à la con europe
europe europe écologie écologie europe
ecologie les verts europe
et rapide sur le fait exprès non
[Musique]
j'habite à 7,6 me souviens bien
[Rires]
[Musique]